[Music]
what's going on guys movies they come
and go but certain films stand the test
of time they become nostalgia they
become beloved classics and today we are
going to look into the future and tell
you a few films that we think are going
to become our modern future classics and
we got a pretty cool panel of movie
lovers to talk about it with first ah
great friend of the show he is my
biological father
not really from Access Hollywood Scott
Mann's how it's great to be here another
great movie lover ah you know him you
love them screen junkies plus the movie
fights champion dan the man Merle how
are you so guys uh first let's unpack
this a little bit let's talk about a
couple of films from the past that we
think kind of heart we Holden that kind
of esteem Dan well the one that we were
talked about when we were putting this
show together was the Shawshank
Redemption which is a movie that came
out a little over 20 years ago for a
long time it was a movie that people saw
on cable that people loved and it slowly
grew and grew and now today I would say
20 plus years 22 years after it came out
is now what people will be regarded as a
classic film busy livin good busy died
well without further ado what do you say
we kick off our list of films that will
be beloved 20 years from now let's uh
start with our guest Scott man well
thanks for having me guys I mean I just
got to go with the Dark Knight yes this
is a film that was very popular this is
a comic book based movie that took
itself really really really seriously it
is a brilliant film and it's a film that
really holds up I mean it's been eight
years I think in another twenty it is
going to be seen as an absolute classic
and another thing about the classic
thing is watchability
a movie that you watch over and over and
over again and the Dark Knight is
definitely filmed that I could watch
over and over and over
the Dark Knight is a very good movie
with a great performance in the middle
of it I honestly and I'm a huge fan of
Batman I honestly don't know if I would
say that in 20 years from now is going
to be a classic movie standing alongside
every other thing it's certainly a
classic of the comic book genre yes huge
right now and I think it is a very good
movie I think as for me as time has gone
by some of the flaws that I maybe didn't
see have kind of started to reach the
surface it's not a bad film I think it's
a very good film I err on the side of
Scott but Dan valid points dan what's
one that you see living up to this
billing for me I mean if we're going to
stay in the franchise films because
there's one that came out that I think
is part of a long-running franchise much
like The Dark Knight which is Casino
Royale if no other James Bond movies
existed I still think it would be a
fantastic action movie it's got great
intrigue it's got a great plot it is as
Scott said rewatchable it's an exciting
film and I think that it is up there
with the very few Bond movies that are
legitimate classics like Goldfinger I
think in 20 years it will stand with
Goldfinger as a classic book of
Montaigne
chicken was to give it a me we've had
one Nolan film so far the Dark Knight I
have another Nolan film to add to our
little collection inception he takes you
on this journey
that keeps you guessing that confuses
you course corrects and excites you it's
like no cinematic experience I feel like
I've had in my lifetime more than
anything else yes at inception it's the
layers the layers of that film that it
keeps going from layer to layer to layer
and the bottom level effects layer above
it that effects it layer above that that
effects layer above that it's brilliant
and you know you know we're talking
about movies that are not just
masterpieces here we're talking about
movies that are going to hold up people
are going to regard as classics in 20
years that is a movie that absolutely
qualifies and it deserves to be seen as
a classic in 20 years and 200 years well
I agree I think that I don't think is
necessarily Christopher Nolan's best
movie I think that might be the memento
or the prestige but part of being a
classic that's going to hold up in 20
years is influence and how influential
does an inception
whether you love it or hate it change
the way movies are marketed gap change
the way movies are scored change the way
a lot of these movies look okay this the
way that action is shot like a steps if
you go back at how many movies market
themselves based off of how inception
marketed some how many scores are scored
the way they did it Wow numbers more
than Wow
all right let's move on Scott what do
you got next okay well to the shock of
absolutely no one watching screen
junkies especially my good friend Dan
here I'm going with the 2009 masterpiece
that is Star Trek because Star Trek 2009
wasn't just a great Star Trek movie it
was a great movie period after just
years of just thinking of Wayne shatner
as Kirk and I immediately just took to
Chris Pine and Zachary Quinto and Karl
Urban as these classic characters I
didn't think about the original crew at
all great casting I mean and it's fun
like if that movie is on cable and I'm
flipping through it I keep it on and I
watch it and that's the thing about
playability there is magic that film has
magic and even though I did love Star
Trek beyond which came out over the
summer I still think that it doesn't
have the magic that 2009 has boldly go
where no one has gone before
thank you my Trekkie friend so how
always damn let's hear another choice
stepping out of the franchise show yeah
second there's a movie that I fell in
love with the first time I saw it every
visited a couple of times and a lot of
people I think would argue very
vociferously against this movie and say
it's the opposite of a timeless classic
but I disagree it's boyhood I think
boyhood is a movie that captures a very
specific moment in history it captures
12 very specific years and it does not
try to make those timeless years it
hones in very much on the trends of the
time on the music of the time on the
style of the time and a lot of people
would say that well that just means that
in 20 years no one's going to be able to
relate to it but I disagree because it
doesn't in a very timeless way because
it's not nostalgia exploitation these
are things that are featured in a way as
visual cues to people here now to let us
know we jump to your head or this is
about the time but I think that the
themes of that movie maturity and
growing up the way that you see your
family the way that your family sees you
the way that your relationships develop
that's timeless stuff that's stuff that
everyone grows up everyone goes from
child to tween to teen to adult and it
captures that beautifully just go and
my picture aren't you jumping ahead by
like 40 years or something I'm going to
pick one that's part of a greater
universe guardians of the galaxy
okay why what a fun ride what wonderful
aspects it introduced into the Marvel
Universe
it's such a fun buddy comedy in space
action movie the elements that it
introduced and that brand of fun with
that soundtrack man I could see that as
a movie that I would love to revisit
years from now hey you know what there's
another name you might know me by
star-lord who star-lord man legendary
outlaw I could see why guardians of the
galaxy is on your list I could see where
it would be able of a class of 20 years
from now there was a vibrancy to it
there was a confidence to it and now
could be its own cinematic universe yeah
you know so I could see a point with
guardians of the galaxy I support that
decision thank you Scott Dan I think the
guardians galaxy is a really fun movie I
think the question is going to be how
long does the superhero bubble last and
how many more movies are going to be
inserted into it in the same way that I
think you saw very few westerns emerge
from the 40s 50s and going into the 60s
I think the reason why that is is
because there were so many of them and
that over time they all began to merge
together and you had to be truly
exceptional to stand out from that pack
I think that's where the verdict is
gonna be with guardians of the galaxy
that being said Scott challenged us with
another choice okay I want with pretty
mainstream hits with my first two films
uh-huh my third choice and might be my
favorite of the three is not a
mainstream hit at all but I was talking
about a film that was groundbreaking and
trailblazing and a movie like the
Shawshank Redemption was not a
box-office hit children of men the way
it looked at the very near future
and the way there were technological
advances mirrored against the decaying
infrastructure reminded me a whole lot
of Blade Runner another film that was
not well received critically or
commercially when it came out
on June June of 1982 but it's now seen
as one of the most groundbreaking films
of all time children of men is the Blade
Runner of the 21st century you just put
that movie on the top of my ReWalk good
awesome no lie no lie
I got an iTunes that stuff yep dan well
I feel like this kind of mixes
everything we've talked about yet it's
post-apocalyptic future it is part of a
franchise but and also one of the most
original movies I've ever seen my last
pick is a movie that came out just last
year some people might say that I'm a
little premature on this I
wholeheartedly believe that people will
still be talking about this movie in 20
years and that is Mad Max fury road the
other Mad Max movies road warrior and
the first Mad Max particularly are
already I think
bordering I wouldn't quite say that
they're classics but they're definitely
well road warrior definitely this movie
I think stands head and shoulders above
any other Mad Max movie there's people
that don't like this movie and the thing
is well it doesn't have any story it's
all flash and it doesn't have any story
and I disagree with that wholeheartedly
it has themes that I think are universal
things about redemption themes about
what to do when you lose everything I
think that this is a visually poetic
movie a man reduced to a single instinct
survive I will say this about Mad Max
fury road yeah okay you talk about how
there are certain people who think oh
it's all visuals there's no story mm-hmm
right here okay okay now I'm absolutely
in the minority on Mad Max I Fest
tonight and that's okay the hardest
thing I think is it's one thing to
champion a film that not a lot of people
like it's not a thing to be in the
minority for a film that everyone else
loves that's the case with me of max
fury road thought it was a great ride I
had fun but for me that's where it ended
the story what's the story
where are they rushing - what's the race
and they turn around and go back wait
why is max so mad I mean all those well
let's do that I agree with you that it
will be seen as a classic I wish I had
the love for this film that everyone
else does well tell you what Scott mance
I still see why people are going I'm
going to put that movie on 20 years from
now and I'm going to say goodbye today
what a lovely day all right the last
bill
on my list yes it's from one of my
favorite directors one of the most
unique directors working today he is a
true ohter he really tries to eat pours
his heart and soul into every film he
makes any it's like he almost tries
sometimes too hard to make a classic
phytic brothers no I'm talking about
Paul Thomas Anderson and the film there
will be blood I think it's a sweeping
epic it's got amazing performances from
Paul Dano and the supporting cast but
the main reason I picked there will be
blood is that I believe Daniel day-lewis
is performance in that film I would call
the towering performance of this era I
have a competition in me I want no one
else to succeed is it iconic it is an
iconic performance and Daniel day-lewis
is at the height of his powers and while
we're talking catchphrases do you know
what movie I would compare the themes to
there will be blood with huh what
Citizen Kane yes we have said absolutely
go much this is about the guy who has
everything and yet has absolutely not a
key what's his milkshake yeah he wants
to drink it up I drink your milkshake I
drink it up don't bully me thank you so
we've each picked three films that we
believe will be held aloft 20 years from
now as modern it's all they're all good
choices classics
I even again I think Mad Max fury road
is a great choice you know what I've
done a lot if you watch children and
then again I will go back and watch Mad
Max again there you go guys try and
catch it let's take a day and watch all
of our movies together all right a long
weekend what do you think should be on
that list what are some major movies
from the past ten years that we left out
and what are some movies that you
disagree that we see what you put that
on your list
Scott Star Trek real you're opening the
door
let us know in the comments section
below we want to know
Scott Matz man boundless energy
enthusiasm energy oh thank you for
gracing screen junkies any time my son
any time my father Dan Morelle thank you
for coming across the hall always great
to have you on the show my man anytime
how excellent and thank you for watching
I'm how Rudnik hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye
hey guys did you know that this end card
works with your phone now I know right
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more